my question was for Quentin as it was
reported the original script for this
was leaked online and until I heard that
you by the way until I heard that you
were rewriting it totally then I read it
and it was great um my question was did
the arm did the fact that you had
already had a story for this make it
difficult to do a total rewrite and also
second question sorry about that what
would be seeing the bride again and
perhaps in Volume three uh yeah so the
thing about it was um what what pissed
me off about what happened with the leak
was the fact that normally I kind of
finish a script once I'm done with it
I'm ready to go into production but this
was when I kind of wanted to go through
three drafts I wanted to get there I
didn't want to like have to you know
like there's certain plot threads that
were in the first draft that I I wasn't
quite ready to tie up yet but I knew I
had a couple of drafts to go so um so
that's why I was a little disconcerted
when it when it got out there having
said that though you know the my process
was my process so even though I yelled
and screamed about it I kind of kept on
doing what I plan to do so it
you know the second draft and the third
draft is what I ended up shooting and
was where I was going anyway with it so
that kind of just went on the way it
would it just got more public than I
wanted it to get and uh we'll see I
never say never we'll see all right you
know uh when it comes to Kill Bill 3
would really like to do it we talk about
it every once in a while or so all right
we've got we've got to wait for vanitas
daughter to get old enough to go and
kill her alright so we'll see
you